people of the Internets the nominees are
officially in and we can now say for
certainty that Hogwarts Legacy has not
been nominated for game of the year but
not just for Game of the Year Hogwarts
Legacy completely snubbed not nominated
in any of these categories well guys
here we have it the game of the year
2023 nominations Allen wake 2 balers
Gate 3 Marvel Spider-Man 2 Resident Evil
4 I'm sorry excuse me Super Mario
Brothers Wonder and The Legend of Zelda
tears of the Kingdom now I've been
saying for a while and trying to prepare
Hogwarts Legacy fans for the fact that
it probably almost certainly was not
going to get nominated for game of the
year now some of these other things
we're about to talk about I am kind of
shocked about some of those one in
particular but before we get there I do
have a beef to pick with the game of the
year nominees Allen wake 2 absolutely
balers Gate 3 of course Spiderman 2 yes
Mario haven't played it but from what
I've heard yes Zelda tears of the
Kingdom absolutely yes however Resident
Evil 4 one of these ladies and gentlemen
is not like the other now I don't want
to hate on Resident Evil 4 in fact it's
one of my favorite games of all time
yeah you heard me right one of my
favorite games ever made I bought it
when it first launched exclusively on
the Nintendo GameCube all the way back
in 2005 and to this day it is a game
that I enjoy and I can't wait to go back
and play this remake I actually haven't
had the chance yet however this is a
game you heard me right from
2005 why are we doing this why are we
nominating the game here in 2023 I I
just I don't understand why have a game
of the year I mean you're it's literally
called Game of the Year Resident Evil 4
yes they released a remake in the year
2023 it is not a 2023 video game now I
can hear some people now saying well
what about if they make some this kind
of change and this kind of change and
that kind of change when the core game
the core game is essentially the same
game that was released all those years
ago I just don't think it should take up
a nomination slot here I don't make make
another category for it if it wants to
win you know best action game and some
of the other Awards sure but to call it
the game of the year I just don't see
how that fits I mean Liza P would have
been a better fit here Final Fantasy
would have been a better fit here those
games and and several others Hogwarts
Legacy among them I mean you're you're
taking them out of even a chance here by
putting in Resident Evil 4 now again it
may sound like I'm hating on Resident
Evil 4 I'm not I promise you guys it is
one of my favorite games I love it and I
do plan to play this one eventually just
don't think it should be nominated for
the 2023 game of the year now with that
out of the way I will go into this and
fully admit that the 2023 Game of the
Year Awards just overall one of the most
difficult Awards ever simply because
2023 has been just a banner year an
incredible year for video games I mean
the games that we have gotten this year
the level of quality of the games that
have released in 2023 is astounding I
mean it really is astounding there are
any number of games that released this
year some games not even nominated for
this year's Game of the Year awards that
would have won it in other years would
have beat games in other years and this
year the competition was was very very
tough so I certainly want to empathize a
bit with the voters and the nominees and
the people who submitted all these
things because of the fact that it was a
very tall order now all that being said
I do have another bone to pick here for
my Hogwarts Legacy audience and the
Hogwarts Legacy fans out there I want to
try and keep it as real as I possibly
can with you guys I don't have an issue
with Hogwarts Legacy not being nominated
for Game of the Year personally I just
don't think overall that it was that
level of quality it could still be one
of my favorite games of the year and it
could still be one of your favorite
games of the year but just when you
compare it to the rest of the industry
and you really have to start to to pick
and choose you know what really pushed
the industry forward in this area in
that area I can understand understand it
now there are some other areas and some
other categories here where it is a bit
of a surprise that Hogwarts Legacy
wasn't nominated at all the biggest one
in my opinion being where is it I can't
find it here best score and music
Hogwarts Legacy not nominated now this
also happens to coincide with the recent
announcement that Hogwarts Legacy
Soundtrack has been nominated for a
Grammy Yes you heard me write a Grammy
and I don't know how many people caught
this or not but the WB Games Twitter
account right around the time all that
the game of the year nominees were being
announced they just happened to retweet
the fact that Hogwart pyy has in fact
been nominated for a Grammy so at least
they're getting some recognition there
and that I mean the music is one thing
that I just I don't know that anybody
disagreed with how incredible the
soundtrack was for Hogwarts Legacy so to
see it not appear here and that's no
knock on any of these games here you
know I haven't listened to all their
soundtracks I don't want to pretend like
I know what all of them bring to the
table here I've heard several of these
but hogw sey soundtrack was absolutely
incredible they just did such a
phenomenal job of taking something these
familiar tones that we know from the
movie and as someone who's not musically
inclined I don't know all the technical
details and and what each thing actually
means but it sounds so familiar yet when
you compare the two it's very distinct
it's it's clearly something new
something different and I just thought
they absolutely knocked that out of the
park so to see them not get a nomination
that is a bit unfortunate another area I
could have seen Hogwarts like I see
getting a nomination is best community
support here I'm not sure why that
highlight is doing that and then I read
the category and what I had in my mind
doesn't quite fit here now obviously me
being a social media person who has
covered Hogwart pyy extensively of
course I'm going to have something to
say about their marketing and about the
team behind that because the way that
they approached and handled the
marketing for that game the way that
they plugged in to truly Die Hard fans I
mean I don't think they got enough
credit for doing something like a
gameplay showcase which still I think is
an incredibly unique thing I mean I
haven't seen a lot of developers do
something like that where they invite
outside fans and influencers in and then
put just show the game I mean show the
game off in pretty a pretty transparent
Manner and there's some talk here about
you know transparency but then you get
you know game updates and patches they
haven't really been able to do that
haven't been in a position to do that
because they've been getting ready the
Nintendo switch version which is about
to release very soon so not a huge issue
that they weren't nominated there but I
do think they should at least be
recognized somewhat at least Among Us
fans anyway right for the wonderful job
that they did in the leadup to launch
another category where you may have
expected to see Hogwarts Legacy best RPG
not here either you got balers Gate 3
Final Fantasy Liza P sea of stars and
Starfield the first four here really
tough to argue I mean outstanding titles
right here Liza p in particular one of
my favorite games of the year I wish it
would have gotten more nominations in
fact I wish it would have taken that
last last slot over Resident Evil 4 as
the game of the year but hey what can
you do
Starfield I don't know I don't know I
could easily see you putting Hogwarts
Legacy here over Starfield which by the
way Starfield fans probably pretty
disappointed at this game of the Year
Awards as well because Starfield I mean
I think this might be their only
nomination which I thought all of the
hype from Starfield the fact that it was
so recent I thought it might be enough
to kind of carry it through to a couple
more nominations but no it seems like
people have already uh kind of started
to realize that you know maybe it's not
in that upper tier that we were hoping
it would be now they actually split up
their action adventure category from the
RPG category so Hogwarts Legacy is
considered an open world action RPG so I
guess you could decide which one you
would want to put it in it also did not
get nominated for that either you got
Spider-Man 2 Allen W 2 Resident Evil 4
Star Wars Jedi Survivor and The Legend
of Zelda tear of the kingdom and again
here we have some really tough
competition I mean if you're going to
put Hogwarts Legacy in what do you take
out again I would probably go to Res res
Evil 4 I mean it did not release this
year yes I'm a little bit more okay with
it appearing here however overall I mean
I know this this specifically isn't the
Game of the Year Awards but overall
these are still considered the Game of
the Year Awards as a whole and then you
have these different categories so I
just that one just kind of a bit of a
head scratcher I mean I know you want to
have some way of recognizing it because
clearly developers worked on that and
they did a lot of work it wasn't like
just a you know a little visual upgrade
and that was it they did a lot more to
this remake however still a a little bit
iffy that it it appears there the other
four though I mean it's it's maybe you
put Hogwarts like the N instead of Jedi
Survivor but tears of the Kingdom
absolutely deserve to be there Allen W 2
and then Marvel Spider-Man 2 yeah so
just tough categories really overall so
if you're a Hogwarts py fan I think the
next thing that you look to is does
Hogwarts pacy finish out the year as the
bestselling Game of the Year we're very
close to the release of the Nintendo
switch and I wanted to pull this up
right here because we got an update on
tiers of the kingdom it is now sold 20
million units which for an exclusive
absolutely phenomenal now the last
numbers that we got on Hogwarts Legacy
were 15 million however that was months
ago months months months ago I think it
was around May when we got that balers
Gate 3 has also sold a huge amount of
copies so those three in particular as
well as Call of Duty probably going to
sneak into the conversation as well I
mean they've been the best seller in the
US for years it's I think it was Red
Dead 2 I researched this a while back it
was Red Dead 2 was the last game to
actually Dethrone Call of Duty in the US
I still think Hogwart pacy has a very
good chance to do that maybe they're
waiting till the end of the year when
they can have a big announcement after
they've got the switch numbers in to say
here's how many units we' sold I mean at
this point I got to think they're over
20 million the fact that they were 15
million that far ago I think it was May
now we've had a number of Hogwarts Cy
sales as well and then we're getting
ready to release on the switch you got
to think around Black Friday around
Christmas they're going to do even more
sales we're going to have that Hogwarts
Legacy documentary releasing there's
going to be a lot more hype around
Hogwarts Legacy before the end of the
year and who knows maybe just maybe
fingers crossed maybe we'll get a DLC
announcement around I don't know
December something they haven't said
anything official and I know I can hear
you in the comments now everybody's like
they said there's no official DLC no no
no no no go back and read the actual
quote they said no plans at this time
very key difference there guys thank you
so much for watching check out this
video right here next as always thank
you all so much for watching I think I
already said that but I'll talk to you
again soon